[Musica]
Wow Ma quanto sono belli questi funghi
Chissà se sono anche buoni non li
mangerei tutti
con gli occhi celesti di nome Merlino
Merlino voleva sempre dormire proprio
come te Merlino però Merlino voleva
anche sempre mangiare e leccare le mani
non si sa perché
Vitale
Super Mario
che cosa ci fai qua dentro devo
raccogliere tutti i funghetti e le
vorrei dire ciao
no E ora che faccio
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che cosa ci fai qui
svezzamento Play
[Musica]
Ma come ti sei vestita
perché sono vestito da idraulico perché
perché siamo in Super Mario siamo nel
videogioco ti prego Hai aperto una sorta
di Varco spazio temporale dentro al
Nintendo switch abbiamo provato a
raccogliere tutte le monete dici che può
funzionare Secondo me sì io mi fermerò a
mangiare qualche funghetto però
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Mario Sì ma ti sei accorto che non c'è
nessun tubo per uscire qua
effettivamente è solo una stanza piena
di monete come faremo a passare il
prossimo livello forse dobbiamo appunto
raccogliere tutte quante ne volete
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo tornati nella nostra camera
finalmente Che bello siamo ritornati noi
stessi ma è questo
hai rubato un pezzo del videogioco e
come ho fatto io non me lo sono neanche
reso conto ma c'è qualcosa qua dentro
Non lo so proverò però
non si apre Ok prova ad aprirlo piano
Che cos'è
se tornate di cibo Ok Allora facciamo
che contiamo fino a tre e poi lo apriamo
Qualsiasi cosa ci sia dentro
controlliamo va bene sono d'accordo
anch'io
e Stasera risotto ai funghi
volete
un piatto preso
[Musica]
Oh no ho perso un'altra vita
Oh no ho perso tutte le vite basta
[Musica]
attenzione hai perso per 99 volte la
simulazione nella vita reale inizierà
tra 15 secondi per interrompere Ma che
succede Vitale
Vitale
[Musica]
cosa hai fatto qua Stavo giocando Super
Mario dice che fra poco partirà la
simulazione la simulazione
sbrigati sbrigati
quella ma non funziona
[Applauso]
Oh no Ah sì ancora la mia banana
oh che è successo
di nuovo
ma quanto pare siamo nuovamente in Super
Mario nella vita reale Wow abbiamo per
raccogliere le monete Allora dai Guarda
per vincere la partita raccogli tutte le
monete Ma se perdi tre vite rimarrai
intrappolato nel gioco Buona fortuna e
attento ai nemici sbrighiamoci
Raccogliamo tutte le monete e cerchiamo
di non perdere le vite io raccoglierò le
monete al piano di sopra tu qua al piano
di sotto Ok andiamo andiamo
Sì
ma cosa intenderà con nemici non lo so
proprio
Mi raccomando state attenti a non
perdere nessuna vita Ok Ah sì sì io vado
al piano di sopra Ciao Ok ciao io
raccolgo le monete qui allora
[Musica]
quindi
Uffa non ci arrivo Ho un'idea Ciao
Guerrino Tu che ci fai qua
bene ho ripulito questa stanza da tutte
le monete andiamo a vedere l'altra
stanza adesso
Quante monete
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Ehi ma ho raccolto tutte le monete
e non c'è neanche niente da mangiare
quindi mi siedo
Merlino che ci fai qua Ma tu non eri in
camera da letto
Stai attento ai funghetti per terra ok
[Musica]
i nemici stanno aumentando per terra non
posso più scendere da qua Cosa faccio
adesso forse è meglio aspettare qua
Speriamo che Vitale Si sbrighi
buoni funghi preso
ho perso la vita
Scappiamo
[Risate]
[Musica]
Anita Anita dove sei Sto arrivando
Anita Sto arrivando
[Musica]
Vitale dove sei Ma in questa stanza non
ci sono monete quindi vuol dire che
Anita è già passata di qua credo di sì
andiamo a controllare nell'altra stanza
allora
è come Se questo fosse il mio castello
il castello della principessa Peach deve
per forza venire Mario a salvarmi cioè
Vitale Ci sono troppi nemici ora giù
Spero che arrivi presto
Eccoti finalmente Ehi Ciao Che ci fai là
sopra mi sono rifugiata qua perché i
nemici non possono salire qua sopra ma
stai per caso parlando dei funghi sai
perché io prima li ho visti un paio
sotto Pensavo che fossero buoni da
mangiare invece mi hanno tolto una vita
e quindi ora ho solo due vite quindi mi
hanno tolto pure il fungo io volevo
mangiare invece guarda
pensavi che fossero da mangiare hai
sprecato una vita così
Guarda che rischi di rimanere
intrappolato qui perfetto
e se rimani intrappolato qui per sempre
e non ci saranno più le cose da mangiare
lo sai Oh questo incredibile Aiuto no no
no Devi trovare un modo per farmi
scendere da quaggiù evitando tutti i
nemici io non so come scendere da qua Ok
ok Ora ci penso Un momento eh elaboro un
piano per venire a salvarti eh Eh
non lo so cosa posso fare Mmm idea ah ah
arriverò alla principessa saltando su
questi funghetti e una volta lì la potrò
salvare Sì sono sicuro che funzionerà
questo piano andiamo
[Musica]
fatta
Sei riuscito a schiacciare tutti i
funghetti tutti i nemici bravo
Ce l'ho fatta come puoi vedere ho già
raccolto tutte le monete qua bravissima
e ora dove andiamo a raccoglierle e
adesso dobbiamo uscire fuori a
raccoglierle è vero possiamo vedere se
in giardino ci sono altre monete Io per
fortuna ho tre vite Quindi tu devi stare
molto attenti altrimenti rimarrai
intrappolato qua per sempre no no no no
no no se poi senza cibo No no no io non
voglio perdere tutte le vite a rimanere
senza cibo andiamo in giardino adesso
[Musica]
Io ho due vite tu hai solo una vita lo
affronto Io ok tu allontanati
che facciamo Ho un'idea
Ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Mario principessa Beach Ma che succede
un'altra Challenge
nuova sfida per voi Challenge nascondino
Chi perde nei primi tre turni avrà una
penitenza nel turno finale Good Luck hai
sentito dobbiamo giocare a nascondino e
chi perde i primi round avrà una
penitenza nell'ultimo round
mi raccomando Poi lasciate un bel mi
piace se volete un'altra Challenge dei
videogiochi nella vita reale lasciate un
mi piace qua sotto e iniziamo con il
primo round 3 2 1
Devo trovarti io Mario conto fino a 10 e
poi ti rincorrerà un 10.9
no aspetta Io vado
scappiamo la Spadaccini dove mi nascondo
dove mi nascondo Ah idea
mi nasconderò qui su quest'albero così
la principessa Peach non riuscirà a
trovarmi
Sì
l'ho fatta ti troverà la Principessa oh
oh oh Spero di no
Io
ora principessa dove sei Mario
Spero che non se n'è accorto
siamo nascosti proprio bene visto che
non ci ho visto qua sopra visto che non
ci ha visto No
Mario Mario ci ha visto aiuto ci ho
visto come faccio adesso no oh oh oh
[Risate]
[Musica]
non mi sono nascosta tanto bene Sì
principessa pizza fritta il primo round
Questo vuol dire che adesso dovranno
nascondermi di nuovo io secondo round
deve nuovamente nascondersi Mario
Speriamo di riuscire a vincere così
evito la penitenza sei pronto Mario a
nasconderti di nuovo tanto ti troverò 10
secondi
Ho un'idea spiamo Mario dalle finestre e
vediamo dove si nasconde Eccolo lo
vedete dove sta andando
si sta nascondendo dietro quell'albero
ma si vede benissimo che è nascosto lì
pensa davvero di riuscire a nascondersi
dietro a un albero
[Musica]
Sei una cosa dentro alla Palma ma che
sta facendo con il tagliaerba Mario Ma
che fa sta tagliando l'erba
vabbè andiamo a cercarlo sono sicura che
è nascosto in giardino e probabilmente
lo troveremo Subito andiamo
Ma questo Kart non va abbastanza veloce
mi sono sbagliato questo non è il gioco
Mario Kart questo è Super Mario
nascondino nella vita reale Oh no ho
sbagliato mezzo questo non vi serve devo
forza ho trovato la soluzione venite
Guardate che cosa qui rotolone d'erba e
mi arrotolerò qua dentro come un burrito
sarò l'ingrediente speciale questo
burrito Hahaha
non c'è nessuno proseguiamo e adesso vi
posso arrotolare C'è un problema c'è un
problema no Merlino No mi sta
nascondendo aspetta no
Aiuto Non mi far cadere Devo trovare una
soluzione per nascondermi meglio
castrato sono rimasto incastrato questo
tubo d'erba non riesco più ad uscire da
qui aiuto Devo trovare una soluzione
prima che arrivi la principessa Mmm devo
fissare a Mario
qua c'è il tagliaerba
Ecco il tagliaerba che stavo usando
quindi forse è qua vicino vediamo dove
sei Mario tanto ti trovo
[Musica]
ho sentito un rumore strano
Merlino aiutami a trovare Mario molto
strano ho visto che Mario si nascondeva
dietro a questo albero ma non è più qua
Forse è tornato dentro casa e non si sta
più nascondendo qua in giardino
ho visto qualcosa di strano laggiù
Che cos'è Ma sbaglio c'è un pezzo d'erba
lì
[Musica]
c'è qualcosa che non costa
lì
sono riuscito a vincere io questo turno
questa volta ti ho fregato
quindi ho vinto io questo turno Ora
tocca a me nascondermi pronti per il
terzo round 3 2 1 1
ho deciso di nascondermi dentro casa
invece che nascondermi in giardino e mi
nasconderò sotto al tavolo
9 10 39 e 40 andiamo ho sentito i suoi
passi sulle scale scendiamo andiamo a
controllare insieme strano
non sembra esserci Forse si è nascosta
bene Andiamo a vedere potrebbe essere
qui
ma qui non c'è Dove si sarà nascosta
pitch andiamo a cercare Cerchiamo meglio
forse si è nascosta in questa armadio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
a prendere ti vengo a prendere
Beccati questo
Ciao ciao arrivo non ti permetterò di
scappare uovo
quindi tu hai perso due turni io ho
vinto due turni Tu hai vinto solo un
turno quindi la penitenza dell'ultimo
round per favore
hai perso Preparati per la penitenza
Oh no che cosa succederà adesso
che cosa è successo il mio costume da
Mario oh no non riesco a guardarmi
neanche i piedi
principessa principessa
[Musica]
la penitenza Oh no sono principessa
Mario ody Maria o principessa Mario non
riuscirò mai a nascondersi con quel
costume gigante
devo trovare più spazio per nascondervi
Con questo costume gigante bene Andiamo
a prendere Mario principessa Ho anche
preso la banana da tirargli addosso vedo
qualcosa qua ma non è riuscita a
nascondersi per niente guardate
Ma chi sta facendo
[Musica]
Guarda che ti ho visto
si è in realtà la principessa ha fatto
beccati questa parola
aiutiamo la principessa dal sarto Grazie
principessa da principessa
posso almeno tornare Mario
sei tornato
sei un po' principessa Anche se ha
funzionato
avete completato la Challenge Missione
compiuta
no
[Musica]
no no no
ma Vitale Come ti sei vestito
Mario
Let's play Tu sei vitale non Mario no
Super Mario
non capisco si può sapere perché ti sei
vestito così poi ti devi trasformare
anche tu dobbiamo raccogliere tutte le
monete e sconfiggere il drago nel
castello e io non voglio né raccogliere
monete nel sconfiggere nessun Drago Ma
sì certo mi aiuterai in questo anzi
iniziamo subito la trasformazione Dammi
questa
[Musica]
cosa hai fatto
Let's play In cosa mi hai trasformato
la principessa di Super Mario Dimmi come
faccio a tornare come prima Ma perché
vuoi ritornare come prima perché io
voglio essere me stessa non la
principessa
ancora con queste monete non voglio
raccogliere le monete voglio tornare
come prima Allora guarda ti porto a
farti vedere allo specchio Così vedi
quanto sei bella va bene andiamo a
vederci allo specchio andiamo quello che
vuoi
ma sono anche bionda
e questo vestito
Beh il vestito non è niente male
Vedi che mi piace già No preferisco
tornare come ero prima se vuoi tornare
come prima dovrai Allora trovare tutti
gli ingredienti Slime Beh diciamo che me
la cavo abbastanza bene a trovare gli
ingredienti Slime quindi potrei anche
riuscire
a tutti
No assolutamente Sono principessa Peach
può tenere il vestito e la corona
neanche
i guanti no i capelli biondi Ok capelli
biondi Sì
no non è vero E allora troverò questi
ingredienti Slime tu non potrai
impedirmelo tornerò come prima E dovrai
trovarti un'altra principessa Peach per
raccogliere le tue monete o quello che è
Questo lo vedremo
Andiamo ragazzi riusciremo a trovare
tutti
mi sta rincorrendo con quello strano
fungo chiudiamolo Ah ah ah
ok l'abbiamo chiuso fuori Spero che non
riesco ad aprire la porta comunque
dobbiamo trovare tutti gli ingredienti
Slime per tornare come prima Ah devo
dire che questi capelli poi blu blu
questi capelli biondi non mi
dispiacciono Poi cosa ne pensate sto
bene bionda o sto meglio con i capelli
castani Vabbè comunque dobbiamo
sbrigarci adesso come sempre iniziamo a
guardare qua nello studio in genere si
nascondono sempre molte cose qua
Cos'è quella scatola strana guardate
non c'era prima questa scatolina qua
sopra
a un punto di domanda sopra
forse una trappola è una trappola messa
da Mario per trovare tutte le sue
monetine come dice lui
questi guanti non riesco ad aprire un
bel niente
[Musica]
se la ciotola
e poi la spatola rosa che si abbina con
il mio vestito devo dire evviva finora
sono stata molto fortunata devo dire ok
via libera andiamo di qua
[Musica]
Guardate un po'
la soluzione per lenti
Ecco proprio qua Devo dire che questa
Challenge sta andando abbastanza bene
mi aspettavo che fosse un po'
Ma che cos'è questo
[Musica]
Oh no Mario mi ha tirato uno di quei
funghetti malefici Ora ho solo una vita
e ho ancora da trovare il bicarbonato e
la colla e la soluzione per lei è qua
per fortuna anche se mi ha preso sono
riuscita a prenderla però abbiamo solo
una possibilità sarà molto difficile
proviamo a controllare fuori in giardino
Ok ragazzi siamo fuori in giardino
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa qua anche
voi tenete gli occhi bene aperti e
ditemi se vedete qualcosa
e Mario Guardate è entrato nello studio
sono scappata giusto in tempo sta
cercando di tirarmi il fungo ma non ci
riesce perché c'è il vetro Ma Mario è un
po' è un po' tonto
non puoi farmi niente qua Hahaha
Ciao ciao Mario ciao ciao
vediamo un po' a volte ci sono anche
cose nascoste qua nelle Palme
fungo
è un po' Strano questo fungo è enorme
coloratissimo forse un fungo velenoso
che dite Prova a prenderlo
[Musica]
ha degli occhietti che carino
prendiamolo Eccolo qua è super carino ma
non so se è un fungo velenoso Forse è
meglio se ci sto attenta lo tocco solo
con i guanti
so che il fungo mi abbia dato una vita
in più perché questo non è uno di quei
funghi malefici di Mario Ma è un fungo
buono Grazie funghetto ma ora
continuiamo la ricerca
ma era proprio qua il bicarbonato non
era proprio qui davanti a me non me ne
ero accorta grazie funghetto mi hai
portato un sacco di fortuna ora mi tocca
tornare dentro da Mario ci vediamo dopo
andiamo
Mi dispiace per te Mario ma anche se mi
hai colpito con il tuo fungo malefico Io
ho avuto una vita in più Grazie al
funghetto buono Oh no Quindi ora scappo
Hahaha
Ok Sembra che non mi stia seguendo
chiudiamoci Qua in studio qua Ragazzi
abbiamo il bicarbonato la soluzione per
lenti la ciotola e la spatola manca solo
una cosa
la colla devo stare molto attenta però
perché ho nuovamente soltanto una vita
anche se avevo preso un'altra vita
grazie al funghetto poi Mario mi ha
preso con il suo funghetto e quindi l'ho
persa nuovamente e quindi ho solo una
vita mi è venuta in mente una cosa
proviamo a ricontrollare dentro al cubo
magari c'è qualcosa vediamo
No non c'è niente dentro Vabbè apriamolo
lo stesso
Ecco come non detto dentro non c'è
niente aspetta un momento
[Musica]
Che cos'è questo foglietto
Che cos'è Secondo voi
sembra il cappello di Mario
disegnato un po' male Devo forse usarlo
per sbloccare qualcosa Pensiamoci bene
Cosa vorrà dire il cappello di Mario
forse vuol dire che nel cappello di
Mario si nasconde qualcosa
la colla potrebbe essere nel capello di
Mario Cioè nella sua testa quindi dovrò
trovare il modo di togliergli il
cappello e vedere se c'è la colla sempre
sperando che questo sia un indizio buono
un vero indizio un vero indizio giusto
però dobbiamo provare perché altrimenti
non sappiamo dove cercare Mario
Eccolo è arrivato subito
Vieni qui devo dirti una cosa
Vieni Mario devo darti Aspetta un
momento non tirare quel fungo perché ho
solo una vita
[Musica]
Aspetta devo darti una notizia ok con le
notizie ho cambiato idea
Ho deciso che verrò con te e catture no
com'era prenderemo tutte le monete e
andremo a sconfiggere il drago nel
castello Sì sei contento però ho solo
una condizione quale
dobbiamo
scambiarci
il cappello
È impossibile ma non si sposta non si
toglie mai il cappello ma aspetta tu
prenderesti la mia Corona e io il tuo
cappello
cappello e Corona
Ok allora ho un'altra condizione
No come fai se mi tiri un funghetto
perdo tutte le vite poi non potrò venire
con te a prendere tutte le monete
Allora l'altra condizione è che prima di
partire per questa avventura Tu dovrai
fare un pisolino
sbaglio allora fare il pisolini dormire
tanto Meno male devi dormire qua però ok
Va bene ok Dormi eh però devi dormire
molto e riposarti molto altrimenti non
potremmo partire per l'avventura
Vai dormi pure Vai vai a riposarti io
starò qua a guardarti
Merlino
Merlino Non svegliarlo Vieni qua
No Merlino No tu devi dormire ok Tu
dormi mi raccomando Merlino Vieni qua
vieni qua vieni qua Bravo lascio dormire
no
sotto per le barbiere Oh maledizione il
mio piano non sta funzionando
Merlino vuole svegliare Mario O forse
vuole avvisarlo quindi Merlino dalla
parte di Mario Merlino
vieni qua vediamo se mi segue anche se
ho paura che rimarrà con Mario Merlino
no come faccio adesso con Merlino Mario
non si addormenterà mai
Ok Merlino è uscito Mario Si sta
addormentando
Speriamo di rendere la colla dal suo
cappello Facciamo silenzio
[Musica]
per fortuna sta ancora dormendo
Merlino no no no no Non svegliarlo
ora dobbiamo fare lo Slime in super
silenzio
sta dormendo vado a mettere la colla
la ciotola
[Musica]
protezione per
lenti
Merlino è salito
sul letto dobbiamo sbrigarci
Ecco fatto Slime è pronto ma non capisco
perché non sono tornata come prima Mario
aveva detto che se trovavo tutti gli
ingredienti Slime facevo lo Slime sarei
tornata come prima ma sono ancora pitch
forse devo svegliare Mario e devo fargli
vedere lo Slime Mario
Devo dirti una cosa importante
Mario
svegliati Mario
[Musica]
sveglia Mario prova a fargli il
solletico sotto il braccio
Vittorio Ciao Mario Devo dirti una cosa
importantissima
[Musica]
Guarda hai fatto lo Slime Sì quindi mi
dispiace ma io devo tornare me stessa e
va bene Hai vinto Allora mi devi dare lo
Slime e mi devi ridare il gioco
Slime io adesso gioco
Allora sei pronta prontissima Let's go
[Musica]
Wow Sono tornata a me stessa sono
tornata Rita ma Mario ora Tu cosa farai
andrò a raccogliere tutte le monete
Se cambi idea sai come chiamarmi e
arriverò subito da te
ok Ciao Mario
Dai fammi
che stai facendo Sto giocando a Super
Mario e sto anche vincendo Super Mario
Wow che bello Anch'io voglio giocarci
voglio giocare con Luigi Aspetta ora è
il mio turno sto giocando Io adesso
aspetta devo finire il turno Va bene
aspetto Ho aspettato 10 secondi Voglio
giocare Io sto giocando Io con Mario
adesso giochi tu dopo con Luigi Uffa
posso giocare adesso mi stai distraendo
e mi stai facendo perdere
No dai fammi giocare Vuoi giocare
davvero è mio lascialo giocattolo
e tu tu Sì
ma tu sei e tu lui
E tu invece chi sei Mario
Mario Maria
è successo di nuovo la trasformazione
andiamo
non posso rimanere così come Super Mario
o Super Mario se devo togliermi i baffi
sono troppo fastidiosi Toglimi Ma sei
sicura mi danno fastidio
Come no sono i battiti un videogioco
penso che funzionerà aspetta
conta fino a tre Ok uno due
[Musica]
adesso li baffi adesso non ce li hai con
i baffi e senza perché hai voluto
litigare come l'altra volta Dobbiamo
solo trovare un sistema per uscire
magari ci sarà una Challenge da fare
hai sentito
c'è un rumore che proviene dallo studio
vieni
cos'è
viene dal Nintendo
se vuoi tornare normale Trova tutti gli
ingredienti Slime si troverà per primo
tornerà normale quindi siete l'uno
contro l'altro quindi dobbiamo giocare
uno contro l'altro questa volta ma come
l'uno contro l'altro quindi chi perde
rimarrà per sempre così Beh allora che
la Challenge
cerco di qua cerca di qua oh oh oh oh io
vado di qua allora io Ok ragazzi Luigi è
andato di là cioè Vitale cioè Luigi
Vabbè io quindi Proverò a cercare gli
ingredienti in studio ma mi raccomando
se non avete ancora lasciato un bel mi
piace lasciate un mi piace e se questo
video raggiunge i 30.000 mi piace dovrò
anche cercare gli ingredienti Slime
nascosti dal
funghetto Merlino Mi raccomando non devi
allearti con Vitale cioè Luigi capito
Devi allearti con me Mario cioè Mario
non ti alleare con Luigi ma è pieno è
troppo preso dal sgranocchiare il suo
giochino quindi spero che aiuterà a me e
non Luigi siamo in studio guardiamoci
bene intorno e speriamo di trovare gli
ingredienti prima di Luigi vediamo un
po'
qua non c'è niente
forse qua dentro
No una candela
una colla ed è verde quindi forse era la
colla per Luigi ma ora è mia
vediamo un po' forse qua dietro
nella pianta Guardate la paletta vediamo
se c'è qualcos'altro
qua nascosto da qualche parte
forse qua dietro no
Guardate un'altra paletta
era nascosta benissimo Ho già trovato
tre cose la colla verde e due palette
una rossa e una verde Quindi immagino
che una fosse per Luigi ma queste sono
mie Adesso almeno so che lui non troverà
queste cose prima di bene ora Direi Dove
possiamo andare a trovare le altre
ingredienti forse potremmo uscire fuori
in giardino Che ne pensate
magari usciamo fuori in giardino
Ma che succede Merlino Ma che cos'è
questo è una tartaruga
Luigi mi ha colpito non c'è più la colla
e la paletta verde mi ha colpito con
questo ed è scappato mi ha rubato gli
ingredienti o un'ora lui in vantaggio su
di me Merlino dobbiamo fare qualcosa
dobbiamo trovarlo subito e prendergli
nuovamente gli ingredienti hai capito
ora o io questa tartaruga io la posso
tirare io in testa e rubargli gli
ingredienti cerchiamolo subito ah eccomi
ce l'ho fatta Sono riuscito a prendere
colla e paletta troppo contento Allora
vediamo
un punto vediamo se troviamo
fuori riusciamo a controllare fuori
vediamo se c'è qualcosa
non ne sono sicuro
Meglio se mi do un'occhiata un po' in
giro ma che ritrovo qualche altro
ingrediente qui Sono stato abbastanza
fortunato per il momento
c'è qualcosa là fuori forse è meglio se
la vado a prendere prima che arrivi
Anita
[Musica]
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
aiuto aiuto
aiuto via via via
fermo fermo fermo
dov'è andato si è nascosto
dove se n'è andato
l'azione
Uffa stavo quasi per prendere Luigi ma
si è nascosto da qualche parte vabbè già
che sono in giardino cerchiamo gli
ingredienti qua Ah Non so se avete visto
prima mentre Luigi si stava guardando
intorno ho trovato la colla Ora anche io
ho la colla non solo Luigi che me l'ha
rubata
a te
c'era lì io cosa c'è dentro
magari una trappola vediamo
non riesco ad aprirla
il bicarbonato Guardate
mettiamo dentro anche la colla
e prendiamo la scatola sono tornata in
studio ho ancora la tartaruga Perché
Luigi è sparito e ho il mio cubo in cui
ho recuperato questi ingredienti
bicarbonato colla
e paletta Quindi se non sbaglio Vitale
cioè Luigi ha la colla e la paletta ma
finché non è il bicarbonato non potrà
fare niente Spero che lui non abbia già
trovato la soluzione per lenti Però come
facciamo Andiamo alla ricerca della
soluzione per lenti e portiamoci la
tartaruga nel caso che lo incontriamo ah
ah Ce l'ho fatta non vi ho trovato
Che cos'è quella cosa lì vi faccio
vedere guardate C'è una cosa stranissima
lì Cos'è questa cosa una banana sembra
andiamo a prenderla
Varano eccola qui chissà cosa servirà
di certo non per fare lo Slime Ma
probabilmente la potrò lanciare contro
Mario o Maria o Maria
sicuramente ci aiuterà
aspettate
è quello
non mi dire
sono fermetti finalmente Che bello ho
già la colla la spatola la soluzione per
lenti mi manca solo il bicarbonato
sono troppo contenti più anche questa
banana C'è qualcuno lì che vi sta
guardando
qualcuno è un po' arrabbiato là dietro
Chissà Ah mi sta minacciando mi vuole
tirare
la torta ho trovato Che cos'è quello una
banana e la soluzione per lenti Uffa
Tanto ora vengo a prenderla
andiamo Luigi ha trovato l'unico
ingrediente che mi manca ma ora usciamo
fuori e gli tirerò la tartaruga in testa
anche se lui ha una specie di banana ma
non penso che serva a niente
e tu no hahaha
non mi prenderai
maledizione
nascondiamo qui ci nascondiamo qui
dov'è
Luigi
è venuto un'idea lasceremo la banana qui
così scivolerà
[Musica]
è caduta
hai capito
Ragazzi abbiamo tutto
soluzione
con le paletta dobbiamo sbrigarci adesso
bene Ora non mi resta che creare lo
Slime per tornare alla Anita Stories di
sempre sbrighiamoci con la glitterata
soluzione per lenti e
bicarbonato Ok C'è tutto iniziamo a
mescolare lo Slime si sta creando manca
poco adesso
lo Slime è quasi pronto
[Musica]
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
Lo so che tu in tutti gli ingredienti e
stai per vincere però io non voglio
rimanere Luigi voglio ritornare il
Vitale di prima ti va si aggiungono
anche la mia colla così almeno vinciamo
entrambi Beh effettivamente potremmo
anche vincere in due invece di vincere
da soli non mi vorrei mica lasciare qui
a mangiare funghi e bucce di banana dai
E va bene Aggiungi la tua colla grazie
grazie La metto subito perché con la
verde così verde e oro diventerà un bel
Marrone Diventerà uno Slime orrendo
lavoro
disco pronto eccolo Ce l'abbiamo fatta è
uscito verde
Eccolo è pronto Guarda è uscito verde
con i glitter oro
perché non Ciri Trasformiamo in noi
stessi
effettivamente non lo so come dovrebbe
funzionare non Ecco perché non torniamo
normali forse dobbiamo solo tirarlo
proviamo
ci Che bello Abbiamo vinto assieme Mi
raccomando adesso Ricordiamoci di non
litigare mai più per i videogiochi Sì
hai perfettamente ragione questa volta